But to answer your question it's getting
better it's getting better and I think
like the situation me and moneybag your
head I believe that helped a lot of
people out you know what I'm saying like
me and him come me and him reuniting and
coming back together and showing the
city the culture like like you can you
can't get over you can move past stuff
yeah you can you know I didn't see I
didn't say any real gangsters like in
the streets that have bodies on both
sides I just seen them come together
just for the for the you know what I'm
saying like you know what I'm saying for
the betterment of the youth you know so
I haven't seen it you know so it could
be done but a lot of people pride in a
way and then his new generation they
just I don't know